[Music]
americans
hello i am magical fingers and and and
passionate beliebers in the entrance hall we
started by the gardens in
in one wheel and how did the cry and
discreet
i christian utopia and dac
sd waiting for the in my pocket and coming
or christ and the in the us and in the hall
by a bunch of people working profit
definitely a profit that is place they
never been full or goal just ab
flatten the door and start in one
trainee looking and hoping for over 20
years before that my funny face to face
and they have a synthesizer in the village
gate bridge of light there so that was the
start min and
centuries oh oh barbie charles and again
is a then extreme degree and medical
grégory then extreme degree and
increasingly
I saw an extra vegan implausible lodge
and so is oh bug in the form of bommel
a science to cache to
Scientology messenger so a hey so
so italy voters with anna and across
the export of night with hefty that song
of a ears character of the I start the
solution none the gather and were
supercharge in the nike 16th will you
improve your own food and reality win
and generally way in the game along
the beach boys organic no matter how
or alternatively the idea that ar
drone
therefore, the media infrastructure
how the entertainment at your whole
azkaban us at the irish specialist
creating a breath of life including
presidential politics of john f
kennedy entry rain to chat
so in the
the pim muda for download run to explore
all these birds
american price in astana family
you can be president but then i love this
history and assign a toujours des indes
come all the brands of the begining
was with you come jurriaan dekkers elfs
baby mario what we want we warm you
believe in a thing you and intel too
send just like a by els and the
world
celebrity info wow you can
new campus my orgy from then soon
drove campus management
are you this penny in the world one
banana
how you make realy would like i play
store in white we the market celebrity
culture which was beginners and fridge
more more necessarily
call her in when or other people or
red gray parker pens grating bar about
being famous pm for such a c & a week
drove bed week again in Hollywood week
to rescue
the culture industry started
and and and then the key microbox pc
industrial complex web series in the burden
few decades
more than ever more the in the body for
possible for papers and cpm yourself
however you go this was a primary goal
for people and chin and swimming facility
sidewalk than the finish line more a
uniquely by noticing but more here then
in your there so and and and you get briana lee
tower bridge was my hobby hybrid
of the fictional and the sewer for the lesson
well generation again that mother between
worlds to is is prompt in the in
warm
Intermedia stream wants that name in oil
hear who all those shows to calberson when
there were chosen television two hours
wonder in and and that a different life or
nobody's become the famous orgonite
youtube and that your iphone career
instagram
image of an eye for doing almost nothing
or not a la
so and so familiar
baked that trump here you date
unlike any normal politician union
person or or business normal business
torselet to how my visitor fit
who was a bib he was a show
business liberty hair inside
use a member the dummy dummy half-way
after all and then so the sprint
anciaux
on printers and slippery pettersson
spark plug was the start planning 'himself
before 3 p.m.
us primark in ow in the best word
this qualifying for president
yes electrically or under actor is also possible
for now and almost had fun
all wishes and and and and oil
when they give century in of rules
after she came up with hollywood
this is the fitting so this is kai bai bo
go directly from most played myself only
all reality television program to being
president and work we proving the sure
power '
or in the times longer the un and kim yes
hey we sober withholding agent money
but by us or the middle armani
in or full of opportunities the bios flash drive and
normally on our business and chairman
and by his famous choose star usa store
and that's why she won the nomination
and just where everyone like all comments
american stafford shape is cabbage
confirmation bias widget oh aj believe
is he wants
iwork for often saussure fact or fiction
is that comfort
my bridges bingley's americans long the
for charges and then the dead plague of
confirmation bias and that acquaintances and
get the very beginning
hmm there within the new world nobodinoz
inside now I want to go save
levels and the chances of your interest
I have you but my life and go there
because it's going to be awesome and perfect
and upgrade your night and a great day
i knew in utopia so maybe walked that way
and that it
have devices anger blue boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh not in thever and
in the game that that was to there is any
notice that and he worshiped camping check
by
but the not a survival by reality
check the stock market side in this software
where most people know
artu napoli that tomorrow and so it will
off
following exactly and entries and they
became the game prior to be
experience what happened to him after that renewal
remained a junior member
why do I have my cookie conspiracy
theory type
speaking hans whatever this by and 's
morning private
the palmers wanda like a house and burden
couple of their special
who fetching public sphere and retrieve
so not so now global warming
categories outside seeing your or night
spiders side a box or separately in the
classroom archer samsung nike air max light
my channel and so and so and so wise
million
the rapper hipster red white red and and
and people will start its members
never took monetary chances short
and already took it
there are five steps in a nut shell
thanks rupee at least a persian
that marches her mind of a time in
your life when you make every dream come
for you have your country
axel immune responses in the campsite
or iwink reason healthcare system that is
better for the and cheaper and and will
cover ever you want
well that they had the port and lina crown
and so wish was the longsleeve defense
so draw in the the public sphere in the
political atmosphere and how you are in the
short time
try not to be verders is a photo from the
euro will provide some people happy body
to a
corinde arbies and sir with me that i
percent on the butter symbols for
down-trap in the primer potions the sets
wheel base no no percent him in that
lake
2017 silently absolutely supporter de zo
island white bed can
paul allah the dozer true believers
do not trade in the I and bake the for
the 20th century
specializes in hanger aymeric internal
was already berry berry
taxi live parsons a bat parties hey
the red peppers and on it magazines and and
everyone was game which version or also
pluck spider in a treat for you
sentry offer guidance on this because
we've got
smart euro russian serbian thing more
be a fax and in the arena media
people's disagree bailie left right
there are warmer until the five o'clock angry de
pan
what has happened with an ebony
inlet
rental first to the red ago
radio where you found the never be in the
more am
national cable television
fox news coming to him and soon the
internet is again words for more than
just a little indifference punching view
but with alternet feng shui how they
could be fair trade we caught it
must be inside a brick oven for more for 2
years or more and so how did i feel
addictive up is a people to the
boogie boy oh boy oh boy oh boy and so
we have the snow infrastructure that
tank is now that i am a new one
conditions so the history of a lovely
fish eye believe is back or slavery
get no sleep liesbeth the dozer that dude
disagreements bad but a in e10 60 others
and she already pernes lesson is still two three
test conditioning got well that's the
kelly young age or ultron
situation where there and public and
hardy
situation for donald trump tower key
malan where wc this new climate change
for more
oh oh oh oh the business this fact rot
feels is an outro latest news thing
and and and the technology the cry and
the technology and
and is it new media infrastructure
now chanel in may not be we in the
vs or will with mythologies
this is is famous when center and and
maybe i will learn your product as one
almost public
000 will grow up a and b dollar camera there
even the this new media situation interest
for the robot and america is in michigan
fraction of applause for unnamed millions
right there is no no way switch ability
to write
world will will be you to bubble and there
salo and and and with their own reality and
not and a people people tree needs to enter
reality b drink
[Music]